[Music]
[Applause]
our good buddy Ross Tucker Westwood One
CBS Sports NFL college football analyst
and Princeton grad and as Princeton was
ready to pull off the upset against
Arizona this is what it looked and
sounded like from Ross Tucker's
household
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
so that's uh Ross Tucker's reaction
yesterday with his daughters they get
ice cream he gets beer
Ross congratulations but uh help me
understand this you had Princeton
beating Arizona yesterday but in your
bracket you somehow have Arizona winning
the next two games after that
do you realize that yes I do I don't
know if that's allowed or not I was
actually gonna try to get a ruling uh
about that from you first of all by the
way that video you just showed and
played I got in trouble from my wife
about that she was not real keen on me
telling the girls that I got to get beer
because Princeton won and then posting
that on social media here's the deal Dan
I felt like I had to pick Princeton
because they're my alma mater I want to
support them but I also want to win The
Dan Patrick challenge yeah I mean I I
want to do very well in it so I what was
I gonna do pick Prince and win that one
when Arizona might go to the final four
might win the whole thing so I picked
Princeton to win the game but then I had
Arizona in future practice am I allowed
to do that yeah you can but it doesn't
it doesn't help you I I'm gonna have to
check with the rules official you might
be dq'd by putting Arizona to win the
next two games after losing last night
yeah I don't know usually the scoring
system is like you get one point first
round to the next three days so I
thought okay I'll go with Princeton but
then I want to get Arizona in case
they're as good everybody says they are
and they keep winning we uh we're in a
quandary here because great story
Princeton knocks off you know a great
team or at least the potential to be a
great team and then we wonder is
Princeton A Cinderella Story I mean
that you get into Princeton
like you already won in life right
no no question okay no question it's
funny because I saw some people tweeting
about how much money the Arizona
boosters put in the nil for Arizona
basketball you know for the Arizona
Wildcat players to get money Princeton I
can tell you right now Dan there is no
nil what I always tell people is you
don't get money like under the table you
get business cards and I'm just telling
you Dan they're way more valuable over
over your lifetime the business cards
that the alumni hand you after a game
way more valuable than whatever these
guys are getting for nil or you know
cash in an envelope or whatever well
congratulations
thank you man that was all I mean you
know how it is that that was very very
cool you know what a lot of people don't
know this Dan my junior year of high
school when I first started getting
recruited I actually took a visit to a
Princeton basketball game and then
that's when they beat UCLA that's when
they beat the defending national champs
now that was actually like a a decent
factor in me choosing to go to Princeton
over Harvard or William and Mary some of
the other ones was I thought they were
like the athletic ivy league you know
they beat UCLA and Hoops they won the
ivy league in football so and then my
freshman year of college they they were
a five seed and they won the first round
and they lost to Mateen Cleaves and
Michigan State in the second round so
brought back a lot of good memories
yesterday and so cool as you know to
experience with my daughters who were at
like a cool age where they loved it it
was great all right well let's move on
to football NFL football free agency
here compensation package for Aaron
Rodgers uh
if you're looking at time frame for this
like The Logical time frame to get this
deal done for both sides so both sides
can benefit this year with the draft
pick by the Jets for the Packers Rogers
gets there gets acclimated with the you
know his new teammates where do you see
this finally Landing
yeah I think it'll get done by the draft
and I think it'll get done before then I
just kind of think it's funny first of
all I don't really understand Dan how
did they not talk about this last week
like how did the Packers and Jets not
say hey let's work out first they could
have talked about it and worked out the
provisions of a trade before they even
let Woody Johnson and the Jets fly out
to California but you know what maybe
the Packers were smart maybe the Packers
thought hey let's let them get all
involved let's let it get out let's leak
that they go when they meet with him to
try to get the Jets fans in a frenzy so
we can get even more out of this but to
me the Jets screwed up by not agreeing
to terms of the Packers before this week
even happened before Rogers officially
told them he wanted to play football for
them but I also don't really buy this
Packers have so much leverage listen
that switches
the second Aaron Rodgers tries to show
up for the first day of the Packers
offseason program and I don't think he
would do that but the Packers don't even
want to let it get to that point they
don't want to take the chance that Aaron
shows up then if he gets hurt I mean
it's a mess so I think my guess is it'll
get cleared up well before then and
certainly before the draft
the Lamar Jackson situation he tweeted
out where he said congratulations
Orlando Brown Jr got a contract with the
Cincinnati Bengals and then he's
basically said he put everybody on
notice that 31 teams are going to regret
this not going after him
okay who's going after Lamar Jackson and
if if so why haven't they you know why
hasn't there even been a hint a sniff of
this is a team that is preparing an
offer here
well nobody's going to go after him in
my opinion and I'll tell you why if you
remember a year ago okay DeShaun Watson
told the Browns you're out
you're out I'm going to Atlanta or New
Orleans the only reason the Browns got
back in it is because they offered him
the five-year fully guaranteed deal so
we know from the DeSean Watson situation
a year ago that Atlanta wasn't willing
to do it New Orleans wasn't willing to
do it in fact from what we know Dan
Jimmy has them in the Browns were the
only team willing to give that kind of
contract there was significant backlash
among the owners from it and DeSean
Watson didn't look real great last year
so it's not like that spurred on more
teams that hey they did it but it was
worth it we have no evidence yet that
it's worth it plus
now you'd have to give up two first
round picks to give that to Lamar and I
think deep down everybody knows that the
Ravens would just match it you know I
don't think bashadi wants to be the guy
that gives out the fully guaranteed deal
and has all the other owners mad at him
but if somebody else does then he'll
just match it and he'll say to the other
owners hey it's not on me it's on Daniel
Snyder or whoever for giving that to him
I just had to match it to keep my guy in
other words Lamar has more value to the
Ravens than any other team for a bunch
of I mean he is by far the most popular
person in Baltimore they've built the
whole organization around him I think
the Ravens are going to match what
anybody else would give and this way
they can say to Lamar hey Lamar you're
on the market Lamar you're out there and
and let him see what he does from there
I still would love to see Daniel Snyder
on his way out because the report is
that he's cleared out everything from
his office that he's ready to sell this
team that you bring in Lamar Jackson uh
Washington fans would actually have
something positive to say about Daniel
Snyder that you got your quarterback and
Daniel Snyder doesn't care what it's
going to cost because he doesn't have to
pay it and then he's going to walk away
with a you know seven million dollar or
seven billion dollars for his team
you know what I think is so interesting
about that and you're right
um first of all you know they just gave
Brissette eight million dollars
guaranteed I don't think they're gonna
also go for Lamar but I know a lot of
people that wanted them too I think it'd
be fascinating if they did I do believe
by the way that the Ravens would match
that but I wonder how the prospective
owners you know the bidders for the
Washington franchise would feel about
that on the one hand maybe they would
feel great hey we got our quarterback
franchise we're back locked up for the
next five years on the other hand that's
a significant yeah
Bezos care about that kind of money if
he got his quarterback and Daniel Snyder
was willing to sell that team to him
I don't think it had it had a big factor
either way I guess my question would be
is it a little bit of a benefit like the
Snyder get a little bit more money for
it or is it considered a risk or a
liability and Snyder gets a little bit
less money for I don't know that
always good to talk to you good luck
with Arizona moving on in the tournament
there
thank you yeah I deserve that I deserve
that now thanks man Westwood won CBS
sports analyst Ross Tucker football
podcast and social media at rosstucker
NFL